this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house what's
happening you bad [__] yes it
is it's wednesday june the 1st the joint
is brought to you by cbd lion
if you're thinking about a cbd i got it
for you see
be the lion the best i've been working
with them for about four years they
helped me through a surgery
and now i'm just getting old and they're
still here with the kinesiology tape
the patches they've got great bath balls
they got a great cream
they got great gummy bears mixed with
melatonin to help you sleep they also
have delta eight
gummies that are tremendous also and
make you see the devil
whatever you need
cbd lion has got it go to cbdlion.com
and read the third party lab results and
see what they got if how it could help
you with your problem whatever it may be
cbd lion they got a new delta eight
tincture that'll make your eyeball spin
like the inside of you you ever go to
las vegas and hit the [__] jackpot on
the [__] three things and the things
keep spinning that's what your eyeballs
will do but hey don't take it from me go
to cbd lion
read learn and see how they can help you
and how you could
take better care of yourself
cbd lion pressing code joey joint or
church and get 20 off your first order
at cbd lion the joint is also brought to
you by another long-standing company
that i love and trust on it
from the shroom tech
sport
which will help you with
lung power the shroom tech immune which
will help your immune system if you fly
whatever the hell you do new mood but
the flagship
alpha brain its nootropics to the third
level and now
we've got the black label alpha brain
they have alpha brain to hydrate you can
just rip open the package just like
the ivs and put them in water listen
honor is there for you club bats
kettlebells mace they're there for you i
can't help you with that but as far as
the supplement is concerned i get your
ten percent off when you press in joint
joey or church so go to honor.com read
about the supplements
and help yourself to order one of these
things alpha brain also has a 30-day
money-back guarantee if you're not happy
with the product keep it they'll send
your payment back go to honda.com right
now press in joey church your joint and
get 10 off your first order let's get
this party started it's wednesday
morning you savages
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
so
what's happening you bad [__]
uncle joey here
on june the 1st the [__]
renters do jack
it went by
that [__] fast guys that's how quick
times are going the summer's here
it's a [__] beautiful day to be alive
a beautiful [__] wednesday yesterday
and monday in jersey if you didn't
powder your [__] balls
you're on fire right now you understand
you have a powder room [__] powder
them again bring a [__] powder for
your [__]
it was hot jack and uh it was a great
weekend it was a great monday let me
tell you something
first off i want to apologize about the
podcast monday uh it affected me last
week with the kids and the [__] and
reading it and
you know guys i tell my wife all the
time uh you know i'm an orphan i tell my
wife all the time the scariest day of my
life
was the day i realized i was alone in
this world
it's the scariest [__] day of your
life when your mom goes and your dad
goes and your sister lives in cuba and
you have an uncle around the corner
but at the end of the day
in reality you're alone
the realization i got last week which
you never want to [__] realize you
never want to realize anything sometimes
it's so scary like you rather sit there
like a [__] and not know
but last week if if you're an american
you got to come to the realization that
our kids are never safe
even when we're at work
even when we're at times have changed
that much
when i was growing up as a kid bro
your mom didn't have to come home for
two weeks and you were taken care of
because
it takes a village to raise a child you
know and uh but today moms have to work
you know it's not the same world
moms got to work and break their [__]
back and get home at six and then
change and run to a [__]
karate class or a softball game they
don't even have a chance to think
themselves so it's a different world you
know
if you get off the school bus and i'm
outside and you say to me my mom's not
home whatever i take you and i feed you
you could watch tv here you could jump
in the pool whatever the [__] we have is
yours that's how i was raised
but
a couple years ago way before my
daughter was born a woman who i had no
reason to even trust
said something to me and it was the
smartest thing anybody ever said to me
she looked at me
it was like an epiphany like marilyn
martinez when she told me god wanted me
to stop snorting coke and i was like
[__] this is deep this woman looked at
me and she goes when it comes to your
child
don't trust anybody
period
your mother you [__] i mean she was
like don't trust anybody because
they're not going to watch your kid how
you're going to watch your kid and that
makes sense with all that i mean i trust
my in-laws i trust my you know i trust
them they have children i see how they
behave around their children it's not
like i'm going to leave my kid with
[__] uh you know
uh
the puerto rican dude who was a [__]
pervert in my neighborhood nelson you
know i'm not gonna leave my kid with
charlie a sticky charlie on 148th street
i'm not gonna seek him with the wood
martin the pedophile you know i'm not
going to leave my children with these
people but you know there's got to be
you know we have pools and we have
friends and you know so
that's what it that's why i was i think
that's why i was so down it's not yeah
and i have a little bit of [__]
empathy i can't
imagine what those parents are going
through
i can't i can't imagine that so uh i'm
very sorry but just
that's what the realization i was like
wednesday or thursday it [__]
destroyed me like you know your kids
they're never safe
we thought we were safe with a school
compliance officer
we saw we thought that the if the cops
would come our children would be first
but that's not the case no more america
so strap a [__] perron
it's every [__] man for himself and
it's a new [__] law out there
it's it's a whole new way of the land
and we have to adjust or you're gonna
get [__] eaten up and that's
so i suggest everybody
in the words of my man everybody's got
to clean up their own backyards and take
a look at what we really have back there
and uh
it took me for a [__] ride but anyway
listen i forgot
first off i forgot how much fun
the city of philly was
i
i forgot
and it took jimmy florentine to remind
me
he said he took his kid his ten-year-old
kid to the sixth playoff game against
the miami heat
and he said that every time one of the
heat players got announced at the
beginning of the game the whole stadium
not three guys not a section but the
whole stadium in philly said [__] you
now
i love philadelphia guys okay i
have always loved philadelphia
my first time in philadelphia was the
eighth grade and we went to betsy ross's
house and all this [__] when you were a
kid you're like what the [__] is betsy
ross she's over there making a [__]
flag and [__] it was just a joke and
then we went to [__]
yeah then we went to the nutcracker
suite and we teamed up
with a [__] kramer school from
philadelphia and it just so happened
they had paper clips
and we had paper clips now philadelphia
the city of brotherly love then i gotta
shoot them at you we decided we're gonna
shoot him at the nutcracker suite while
they're performing
and it was us and some philly school
just launching field that's all you
heard the people the performers were up
on stage like swatting [__] paper
clips and they finally said that's it we
can't taken them or we got thrown out
and that was my first experience in
[__] philadelphia okay
my second experience in philadelphia is
maybe a year later not even
my buddy vinnie lynch got rested so
says he's got extra tickets for the
rolling stones me i'm a dumb kid the
rolling stones i had the tongue i knew
what you know sticky thing i knew what a
sticky thing is at that time i knew uh
some girls some girls was a popular
album when i went to see that tour
i knew uh you know sympathy for the
devil
you know you always said boo-boo yeah
you know
and i bought get yaya's out and i heard
the arm and i almost pulled my hands out
of my head because i never heard live
music that sounded so bad
that was 40 years ago
i get in the car with this [__]
vinnie lynch and he starts talking to me
about a hit of acid listen guys i i
don't mind smoking dope and maybe
drinking a bottle of boons for him at
the time
okay that's the level i was up to i was
up to three i was up to a joint between
six guys and maybe a bottle of boons for
him and you're gonna see puking
hallucinogen the whole [__] thing
okay that's who i was in the 8th grade
guys what do you want me to tell you i'm
sorry my tolerance wasn't that high now
that it's high you [__] want to
torture me over it
and this [__] is talking about a
hit of acid
now it's the veterans memorial
memorial day no veterans memorial
coliseum in philadelphia was that the
name of it the vat the stadium
these [__] got a hotel you
could see the stadium like a nice hotel
they got this is 1978 guys
i still remember the streets
having like little water gaps in them
so they had a little island in the
middle i go north you come south two
lanes that way two lanes this way but in
the middle they had grass parts
but in the grass parts they had little
things where dirty people would only
conceive of jumping in there and guess
what
people were jumping in there i'm gonna
hit acid i've never done acid before i'm
in a car i'm [__] 14 maybe i maybe
got a half a mustache and i got the
drizzle around my [__] like the bozo
look like the middle head and fall in
like i couldn't show it to somebody
and we get to the [__] hotel room and
the acid has [__] hit me it's
windowpane acid i didn't open up with
[__] acid three-ways
if you wonder what's wrong with uncle
joey we just found the answer there's no
therapy session when i was 14 i did old
school
pane asset we went to the room
i sat there like a you know a 13 14 year
old kid that i was not knowing what i
was feeling
and all of a sudden they're like hey
it's time to go down and see the bands
who's the opening band somebody said
who's the opening band they're like
foreigner
and on my coldest ice
and i never forget that i put like a
blanket on like a hotel it's [__] the
end of june and i put like a hotel
blanket on because cold as ice went into
my mind like they hit a [__] asset
like when you have i don't know i don't
know guys i don't know
and i'm like i'm not leaving this room
and they're like joey coco
we came two hours to see the stones and
you don't want to leave the room i was a
[__] i didn't know i'm like no i don't
want to leave the room i'm seeing things
i feel cold
and they're like talk
you got to get it [__] together and i
remember i went out there
the stone uh foreigner was ending up
long long way from home that's what they
were closing up with you hear that song
great great album the first album so
and uh
there was a little intermission which
didn't help my [__] cause you know it
took me to the next level of [__]
everything
and then i [__] uh the stones came
out he came out wrapped in an american
flag
with like a [__] fire truck or some
[__] on the end of the fire you know
mick jagger type [__]
and i [__] had to sit there and take
that whole concert on acid not knowing
what happened i knew maybe two songs
beast the burden and shattered and
[__] uh
before they make me run or something
like that they did keith saying and that
was it
we went back to the room i went home and
the next morning i woke up
puke all over my chest because i took my
shirt off obviously when i got home
and there was a big piece of hubba bubba
that was petrified
right there on my chest
i didn't have any hair on my chest oh my
god you know and that was my [__]
second experience of philadelphia so
right there
i'm like you know what i think i'm gonna
give philadelphia [__] breathe every
time i go to philadelphia i get in
trouble i either do acid or i [__] uh
you know
[__] whatever
so
we're sitting here a couple weeks ago
and [__] jimmy goes listen memorial
day i'm going to see
the giants are playing phillies let's go
down that's a four o'clock game i was
like that's perfect because
we're just going to sit around we're
going to be everybody's going to have
barbecues on saturday and sunday we're
going to be [__] one night on people
i would love to go to [__]
philadelphia but then i woke up monday
morning and it's [__]
i got in the car to go to the gym and it
was already 88 degrees at [__]
9 30 in the morning i'm like i don't
want to go no [__] softball game i
don't want to go no [__] baseball
game
and then i went to the gym and i
lightened up a little bit and i saw how
excited my daughter was she goes dad are
you bringing your glove
i'm like why am i bringing my gloves
she's like so we could [__] catch the
balls the foul balls i'm like mercy i'm
not bringing my glove but you can bring
your glove and bring your little hat and
[__]
so her excitement got me excited listen
and his negativity here's when i talk to
people about negativity and how
negativity spreads
i went outside the house yesterday when
i went to the gym i don't know when i
came back and my neighbor goes hey how
you doing you guys are going to the game
she goes get ready to [__] die down
there
between the heat and the [__] savages
something bad's gonna happen i'm like i
know i shouldn't go you know and then i
[__] went to livoti's to get italian
ice and again i saw some guy that he
plays off of my daughter and he's like
oh it's gonna be hot down there i would
rethink my plans and i'm like maybe he's
right and then i'm like you know what
i'm gonna tell him i'm gonna tell my
wife i'm not gonna go you know and i
[__] came home
and she's like all right we're getting
ready to leave it's 12 45 1 o'clock and
i'm like i don't know if we should go
like joey she's really excited you know
what
let's go i had a bad night i couldn't
fall asleep [__] sunday night i don't
know
just it was one it was the first bad
night in like three weeks so i got no
problems with it my percentages are high
i used to have two bad nights a week or
a bad night every other week now it's
pretty [__] calm so i just i just
stayed up and i read i didn't want to
watch tv and i when i got up i only
slept like four hours i was a little
tired i was like you know what i just
wanna
chill today but nobody was gonna do dick
you know everybody was just gonna sit
around so i said [__] it let's go to
philadelphia so we followed jimmy and
his son
and me and my wife and my daughter out
of the other car we had sugar-free
licorice
goldfish [__] the other fit and i
hate goldfish the [__] i hate goldfish
in real life and i go fish the candy the
[__] crackers i really do i don't
know i don't like those goldfish i ate
him as a kid how many [__] goldfish
can you eat enough is enough i ate an
ocean already a goldfish you know what
i'm saying i'm beat the notion of those
[__]
we went down there
we parked
guys you know i'm the first one i want
to come play
we parked
it was
a 75 foot walk
which i
you know it's hot so but it's hot i know
everybody knows it's [__] hot
walk keep your head down and you know
wear a white shirt
whatever and that's exactly what i did i
dressed them white i wore my white
little sneakers
but before i left you guys know me dog i
took
2500 milligrams in edibles i ate eight
of them
at 200 as an aparri teeth for the
afternoon
and i listened to the new sound gardener
the new def leppard i'm on the way back
i needed three thousand edibles after i
listened to that [__]
nightmare of a [__] album
oh my god deflect but just keep singing
[__] high and dry
don't try without mud laying it was not
good have you heard it it's not good i
was listening to it as i was falling
asleep to philly and i told my wife take
that off
i can't do it no much put me to sleep
so i [__] uh
i took some metal blouse i had a roll
joint
for the night before with some [__]
powder in it and i had a ton of [__] in
that joint that's a yeah i was gonna
kill somebody and then i just took a
handful of abx edibles and put them in
the bag and i put them in my side pocket
you know i'm like what am i gonna do
what do you want from me i'm gonna go
down there
maybe i'll bump into somebody maybe i
won't
so we get there easy ride easy walk the
gates open up at 2 30.
we walk in because the kids could go to
batting practice and they get balls
thrown up to them oh my god she loved it
and i'm sitting there
my wife goes do you want to go to
bangkok oh yeah we go over to the thing
and nothing was open yet
no
sausage and peppers no hot dogs no
italian ice no nothing we got there that
early so no i wasn't high i was i had a
great lunch i wasn't hungry
i was down there watching and then it
just got too hot it was really hot at 2
30 out there in the sun we were right
the sun was right [__] there
so i walked
yeah it was remember i just told that
ralphie may [__] baseball story and
here i am going to relive it again we're
right in the same [__] area guys only
i think those tickets were
third base line no i don't know this was
the first base
so i'm sitting there and i go terry she
goes why don't you go up and get you
because we were all alternating like you
know it's not a bad idea so i went up
and sat in the shade people were
starting to come in you know
the vendors were walking towards their
things i'm looking at them like [__]
this is cool it was just great to see a
stadium
earlier you know it was great [__]
and you know there was two people
walking here
four people here two kids it was still
really early
and i just sat there i gave lea a call i
had a call like two of my friends had
called me on the way down there
and i'm sitting there minding my own
business and i and then that now it's
starting to see you know we're starting
to see
five people
i started to see the vendors cooking and
at one point
it smelled
so [__] good at philly stadium guys
and i i found out on the way out that
it's
it got voted like the best food in a
stadium
is that true
they had french fries with crab meat
dad [__] that was out of this world when
i walked over and i'm like oh my god i
didn't bring enough briefing look at all
this [__] food they are not [__]
around and villains
oh my god they have that the guy who
shoots
it doesn't guys it didn't end now i have
my composure i'm sitting there and i'm i
love people watching and if there's any
place
you should people watching
it's in philadelphia
beautiful women beautiful young women
all colors
all sizes you know i gotta admit that
the women in philly all colors
all sizes all of them beautiful and very
[__]
nice i'm like you know what this is
going to be pretty half good afternoon
i'm sat here for maybe 30 40 minutes the
game's about to start at four
nobody's recognized me
this is great you know
i thought maybe somebody would say
something to me like hey come on nobody
nobody was very nice
and i spoke too [__] soon and all of
a sudden i'm sitting there
and i see like a block of guys walk by
like maybe like seven guys
and i envied them
guys i really did envy them because
that's what that was me
memorial day sneaking in trying to get
to that level before
putting enough money together to get a
hot dog a med hat a yankee hat a philly
wherever the [__] you're at you know you
can't replace that in your life i i can
you know i call leah one time and i go
we gotta figure out how to make money
going to baseball games
like just go going to baseball games
like from [__]
boston straight to san francisco one
time in your life
like just all the stadiums do a [__]
thing about the foods talk to the people
i think you know when you retire there's
something that's a great [__] uh
bucket list like i have friends i have
my friend ralph a fuso and his kid dog
do a stadium tour
since i can remember
20 years now the kids graduated college
last week congratulations mr fuso
i mean these people are dead i'm like
and i never frowned on it i never was
like that doesn't sound like i just
never had time and i thought i'd never
have time in a life to
just take a summer off and go to [__]
and see baseball game jesus
that sounds great have you ever been to
baltimore stadium bu power used to have
those ribs outside jesus christ it's
just
america is [__] beautiful when it
comes to baseball
so these eight kids walk by and all of a
sudden
i don't think none of it i'm just like
man how lucky would it be to be 21 again
you know you got to go [__] uber
delivery you're like i'm only doing tube
is enough to get money to go to the game
and then we're over to the game you know
what i'm saying like you just that's
life guys that's what people don't
everybody wants a boat everybody wants
to go down the shore and be kim
kardashian you don't know what it's like
to take any of your buddies
you know you just got out of high school
nobody wants to work my father wants me
to go to work today [__] him you know
nobody wants to work the summer after
high school you just want to live on the
fat of the land and the prophets of
crime
and you're like [__] because that's all
i wanted to do i'm going on 40 years
this is like the best summer of my life
1982. we refuse to get jobs refuse
everybody every parent's like you need
to get a job every time you call for
your friend his father like you and him
need to get a [__] job and you're
like yeah all right [__] him i know [__]
him he's an old timer
but for those guys they were just
like you could see like they were just
plotting [__] like let's chip in and get
fries like they probably bought a ten
dollar bag a week you know and that's
the [__] we never remember everybody
wants an eighth or a pound everybody
wants to be wiz khalifa these guys are
just [__] having a great time
i was at
while i was looking at them
one of them made a quick u-turn
and he came over and this is exactly
what he said to me
because mr diaz i don't mean to bother
you
i would love to do one of the animals
just like this and i looked at him like
oh
and i just looked at him for like i
don't know 10 seconds i'm like nice to
meet you i gave my hand joey you don't
have to call me mr diaz he goes i don't
want to take a picture
he goes i walked past here with a bunch
of guys a couple minutes ago he goes i
didn't even let them know it was you
because i want you all for myself
that's just smelly
he goes but i don't want a picture
i just want to shake your hand and do an
edible with you
like what's the strongest edible you've
ever done
this kid looks to me he goes a 50.
i go listen all i got is a 200 and he
goes done
i didn't even say 100 and he's like done
i'm in
i went in my pocket i go are you serious
now this was i don't know if you guys
ever watched the old churches when i put
edibles with weed and lee would take a
capsule out and be coated with thc
because i put like
i'll take
i'll take a baggie and i'll put 10 of
them in there i'm going out and then
i'll put a joint or two in there and
while you're walking the joint loosens
up and it go it coats these things
they get really ugly and when you eat it
it tastes just like reefer
so
[Music]
oh my god especially when you buy the oh
no no no no
and let me tell you what the kid did
the kid was a trooper
he did not pop it he bit it and it went
on his teeth and i was like oh
and i've been around a long time guys
i'm a [__] dinosaur
you guys know you guys been witnessing
the edibles we've done
i've never seen somebody chew on those
things i will never buy whatever is that
a piece of gum with the [__] flavor
thing inside that is not the flavor
you're looking for
i love abx i love the strength of them i
love the flavor of the gel cap
but i don't think i will love the flavor
of what's in there this [__]
i've been into ranch and he's looked at
me goes thank you god bless you and he
took off and the rest of the game i
thought about this kid
because i knew he was not prepared for
this [__] edible but you know what
it's philly
so for all you [__] that talk
behind my back joey is chewing edibles
don't touch joey's edibles i was in
philly
and there's more so
then
now i'm starting to have a good time my
kids are eating edibles
all right right so my wife shows up
we're going to take our seats we take
our [__] we don't take our seats
i'm waiting for them
so i'm waiting by this [__]
like by the end of my row i'm by first
base you got to walk maybe 10 rows down
and you're right there in the middle but
i didn't have my ticket they were in
somebody's phone you know everything's
in your [__] phone down
so i had to wait and i was waiting there
i started talking to him i'm sitting
there and i told my daughter on the way
down there before we even got in the
cargo attack mercy
we're going to philadelphia
i love philadelphia
but they're savages
so
whatever curse words you've heard before
and all this [__]
it's going to be
tremendous she's like okay dad
now when we just get to philly we just
got the philly we just get out of the
car
we just crossed the street it's the sign
where the players or the personnel i'm
not going to say players because people
are going to go joe you're lying no it's
where the personnel goes in with their
cars in and out
because if it was players there would
have been kids waiting with autographs
that's how i knew it wasn't
but right there by the philly thing
right there where you walk in like
philadelphia phillies there was a
[__] thing and it said stand on the
line and all this you know signs that
tell you
but on one of the signs
somebody drew a big [__] dick with
balls
with squirts coming out of it and sure
enough
i'm holding my daughter's hand and she
goes dad look like looking like oh jesus
[__] cracks before we even walked
into the stadium i'm like that's it my
daughter just grew up today i just grew
up today
so i tell about the curse words and [__]
now when i see a mom with kids
i'm thinking i'm okay right like
everybody thinks they're okay what do i
mean joy what do you mean by okay well
that
you know we're okay nothing's gonna go
bad it's not like somebody's gonna hate
you it's a mom
with three kids and all of a sudden
after about ten minutes the two
daughters were beautiful the son was
very nice and she was really attractive
she was cool she had tats and [__] i
didn't know what to expect i didn't say
it work i meant my business i was just
watching the players you know uh fix the
field and trim and they're doing the
watering it's [__] great man i'm
gonna get a job there i'd love to get a
job at philly state i was told
the guy that was in charge of my role
was retired he was
just amazing we had a great [__] time
with him
so i'm sitting there with these ladies
and hustling i hear the mom the mom go
what the [__] has taken us so long jesus
[__] christ that's the last time i'll
take her [__] slow ass to a [__]
game and i'm like
i'm in philly this is it guys and i'm
not guys now i'm not you know me you
know my language you know the verbiage
that i'm i'm able to [__] throw out
there i was like holy [__]
and not even 10 seconds after that
another woman behind me was just laying
expletives on the air he's [__] these
[__] things are too hot whatever i'm
like wow so now we all go down and sit
down and guys it is hell on earth
it's [__] hot it's not as hot as the
ralphie may incident
but it was up there guys i was sweating
profusely so after the first inning
i i can't take it no more i go i had
four kids
and jimmy and me and their parents
and i just without counting
i go i'm going to get italian ice for
everybody because we're going to melt
and i went and got cherry italian ice
and like lemons i just got a mix of them
and my wife goes i'll help you carry
them i had like four in this arm three
and this song my wife had him but look
how i have the entire nicest guy i got
three in this arm and three in this arm
and it's 95 [__] degrees so i go to
pay and the guy you know you can't pay
with cash what a nightmare everything's
a [__] card so i tipped them
you know 18 percent
do you know the kids came out from mine
they kind of shook my hand they're like
thank you man nobody tips i'm like what
you know we started hanging out it's
awesome you get to the thing and if the
pitch is throwing you can't walk down
because the cameraman is there this was
great it was getting taped for tv
i mean
[__] great yeah hold on well the dude
looks at me goes no no hold on let him
go down the ice cream is melting i don't
want the ice cream to melt all over
these i didn't know when i went to sit
down my daughter listen she looked dead
you're disgusting i go watch she goes
look i had a big red spot so i had to
walk the rest of the day
like i got shot in the [__] heart at
the philly game so now i'm sitting there
and i'm eating the [__] italian ice
and i'm having a blast i'm like i'm not
hot while i drink the italian ice this
is good to know
so i just keep eating italian ices and i
won't [__] sweat to that
but i started eating italian ice like it
was you know
it was [__] hot
and next you know i ran out of entirely
nice and guys you're not even gonna
believe what your uncle joey did next
you couldn't even figure it out
i saw that the guy was saying
frozen lemonade
with tequila and without tequila and
margaritas frozen margaritas guys
the margaritas were [__] delicious 16
ounces guys how long you know me have i
ever told you alcohol is delicious
wasn't i just telling you i was dying it
was so hot
and it was frozen i just told the guy
i'm not walking back to get another
entire night so in the meantime
give me the [__] margarita and right
there i'm like hey you can't walk on one
leg i go in my pocket and i [__] pop
eight of them whatever those 200
milligrams and they're starting to melt
because it's so hot they're starting to
get really gushy in my pocket i'm like
[__] i gotta dispense these
[__]
so i'm sitting there man
and i gotta tell you guys
whatever i was thinking about
whatever insecurities i had the last
couple weeks whatever was on my mind
the rogan thing this weekend
while i was sitting there sweating
looking at that field
any problem i had any insecurity i had
just went
away it was like i was [__] floating
i wasn't high
i when it's 95 degrees and you're
280 pounds you're not going to get high
you're not going to get drunk on a
[__] margarita not one but you need
22 margaritas to get a big fat [__] like
me done especially with the tolerance
i drank that thing
i gave mercy two sips
because it had ice in the top you know
once i drank the alcohol and ice on the
top there was no alcohol in there she
like dad this is good
and i got to be honest i forgot how
therapeutic a baseball game was
there was 70 dollar tickets guys
i didn't go broke over
in fact when jimmy told me there was 70
dollars i'm like it feels like i'm gonna
have nosebleeds tickets no the reason we
went to philly stadium is because they
were saying that
yankee stadium is really expensive and
it's really hard to get in and out of
and shea stadium is kind of rough it's a
two hour hike you know so they just said
let's go to philly and have a great time
and i got to tell you one of my main
concerns in life is that
you know look at the plane tickets
nowadays that's great you could afford
1100 to la what if you had a family of
four and you already got disney tickets
that's four thousand dollars and playing
tickets you know you know these nick
tickets to 220 you know la
laker tickets the cheapest ticket is
[__]
240 dollars under the air conditioner
and you could check it right now i'm not
lying to you and that was 240 pre-covert
that's the cheapest ticket in the
staples center and you'll see it it's
like those say it you're like oh my god
180 and you're like
it's right next to the air conditioner
so
i really
you know a mid-level family uh you know
a family of four could enjoy a baseball
game
i mean it's five dollar waters
i've seen them for eight
i've seen them parade i've seen them
pretend they could yank you more
the sausage and peppers with 10 bucks
you know if i want a sergeant pep i
gotta drive down the shore anyway and
that's five dollars a gallon right so
you know
everything was pretty comp everything
was
you know the margarita was a 20 spot
beers in a can were eleven dollars i
don't drink beer i don't think you're
ten year old kids drinking beer either
so
it made me gave me a little hope that a
family of four
if i did 71 or 70 for those tickets
for 25 i could sit in the middle they'll
upgrade you you know you could go online
and really
that's a hundred dollars for a family of
four even if they want a baseball hat
at 25 bucks or whatever i you know what
considering what's going on in the world
that's not a bad damn entertainment and
listen
it's not just entertainment on the field
it's the entertainment in the stadium
that counts
so after i pop those [__]
eight edibles i'm sitting there and i'm
like this every problem in my world has
gone away i have nothing to worry about
this is
the best i felt in [__] ten years
i looked up i saw those [__] american
flags when they did the the [__] star
stan family banner in the beginning all
that just and we were there on [__]
memorial day i wasn't even thinking
about it that way i just wanted
something to do with my family
and it was [__] superb now
i know a lot of you people
you know not the best for your family
and you want your kids to hear the right
things
[Music]
if you want your family
to hear the right things to grow up like
normal kids
go to philly stadium okay
why do you think i love you i hate them
people they are who i am dave you know
listen man i always love comedy because
of the travel like to these small
cities all you [__] that want
to make people like me and all my
friends the people i
jig with [__] feel bad because we
didn't go international travel [__] you
i've seen things in this country you'll
never [__] dream of and it makes me
proud to be a [__] american and i've
seen them everywhere in san francisco
louisville kentucky
[__] buffalo new york philadelphia
you know i've seen things that
texas you know
tempe arizona i've seen things that have
made me go whatever i felt about this
city
i just feel a lot better about it like
when i go to chicago if you think i'm
gonna come when i go to uh yeah when i
go to chicago
if you think i'm like most people oh my
god the architecture no
i'm gonna see the people i'm gonna eat a
[__] hot dog and a chicago dog with
pickles in it and i want to see that guy
spit the food out while he's talking to
me and just be himself you ever want to
go to the city and see the [__] inner
makings of the city that's what i live
for that acute acute you know in the hot
club and where i need to go eat that's
[__] because all these cities that
have heart cleveland
uh baltimore buffalo these little
[__] cities have one thing that you
go like when you go to cleveland you go
to that pastrami place and they're great
in there that's what they do you know
that's what they they do when you go to
philly
first of all it's not a woke stadium
so if you awoke if you if you want to be
referred to as him his or her if you
want to be referred to all those things
in the wok world it's not going to
happen at philly stadium and if you want
your kids to live in a world world it's
not going to start at philly stadium
because the [__] that comes out of those
people's mouths
i can't even remember all of it i can't
guys i cannot even remember how hard i
haven't laughed that hard like you guys
like oh my god you must have laughed so
much at the comedy store listen
you're gonna laugh twice as hard
[__] philadelphia
eagle
sixer
forget about a flyer game i have not
been to a flag game since 19
right
so i've not even been to a fly i've not
been to a six of fan games since 1983.
you know i have not been to an eagles
football game i went to see the eagles
against the jets
in 93 with randall cunningham at the
meadowlands
and you know i never i don't remember
when the last time i went to see a
[__] baseball game
you know i thought that i kept calling
the jfk stadium where the where the
[__] uh
where the uh
where the phillies played but it was you
know because i thought it was jfk say it
was really that
veterans memorial coliseum that's where
i went to see
them play i went to see
the stones long time ago
the spectrum was where i went to see
like [__] you know
sabbath and the sixes and all that [__]
but anyway
so i take a picture because it was so
beautiful and i know mike saw it because
mike
clicked on it was just a beautiful
picture the scoreboard you know planes
were flying over i'm just like i wish
people understand that it was
it's just a beautiful day to be alive in
philadelphia
whether i got 95 pounds of sweat on me a
red heart you know [__] sticky feet
from the [__] floors well the stadium
was immaculate
guys
immaculate
you could eat off the [__] floors
people were very [__] nice
i must have taken
50 [__] pictures sitting there
people don't even make me get up they're
like uncle joe you don't want to bother
you come over and they would just hug me
and take a picture of me
it was
[__]
surreal it was surreal but then these
two guys came over
and they were like uncle joey we were
sitting in section whatever we saw you
were here we don't want to bother you we
just want to say hello man say hello bob
under then they sat right there and i'm
like oh this is going to be crazy
they were gentlemen they were
philadelphia gentlemen they were yelling
[__] you you know they were doing the
whole thing my daughter's laughing and
luke is laughing and the whole thing is
[__] laughing we're all [__]
loving life we're having a great time
and uh
you know man i'm starting to get high on
these edibles
the margarita i didn't feel i'm not
gonna lie to you people i didn't they
came and went but the edibles were
making me feel warm you know and all of
a sudden i saw a dude an
african-american dude cool as [__]
selling beer beer here beer here and the
two guys like we'll take beers give
uncle joey a beard i'm like no you know
i can't then he's like brother that cold
you're gonna love it this is with philly
love the guy was talking to me like that
man we give our beers with philly love
i'm like what i'm like i i can't have a
beer and i look at these kids and
they're having such a great time and one
guy's like a mailman like they just kids
that work
and they go to games and all this [__]
and i look at them and i go hey
this is how i test these [__]
hey
you guys want uncle joey edible
what do you think their response was do
you think they go how strong is it oh my
god we heard about your edibles they
were like [__] yeah
are these the ones you gave lee
and i'm like yeah they're 200 milligrams
they're like bring them on now it's the
third inning
they pop them they're happy i'm happy i
make a video with them they're like ah
we're [__] jumping up and down
yelling at listen i don't even know what
the [__] score was did i talk about
the score that i even that's how [__]
entertaining this was
but i was just sitting there watching
the baseball game
not listening to the announcers it was
like fight companion only philadelphia
style fight companion with two [__]
young kids who were nuts and they're
yelling at the picture and i didn't know
that the
ex-manager of philadelphia is now the
head manager of
[__] the san francisco giant so every
time he came out
i don't have to tell you the things that
were yelled boo [__] you
your mother go back to here
one time there was two bad calls that
poor umpire he's in therapy today i'm
telling you right now
they were saying things that there isn't
therapy now my two little brothers over
here were yelling and screaming having a
great time but then they turned into my
brother george when he was driving me to
newark for the ufc about eight years ago
it's
the car started slowing down a little
bit my brother george got a heavy foot
you know he's doing 90 talking about
pepe the chef
and all of a sudden
i'm like what's going on with george
he's doing 50.
austin i see this [__] getting
into the right lane he's slowing it down
a bit
all of a sudden we were doing like 10
around that thing and he was doing 10 on
the streets in newark and i go george
are you okay and he's like not really
that [__] edible hit me
i went out to get the tickets from wilco
from ari he [__] left me there
he got so high and so panicked he just
took off from there
that's what these edibles do to you not
these two guys
they were sitting there yelling
screaming
it was guys
looks like i'll be going to philly
[__] state when i got home you know
how many [__] tweets i had from
philly yesterday you know how many
[__] instagram people are like hey
man you come down here again
you hit us up the [__] some guy hit
me one of my patreon guys works for the
[__] phillies and he's like joey
you went to the game and you didn't
[__]
there was one guy that went off on me
he was like
i i think the world of you i went to see
you at parks
you know how day you come to philly
unannounced how dare i come oh
but you knew i was coming
i told you i was going to a game yeah
no
no i got to take the girls over to with
the softball team they're going to walk
the field and run the bases the yankees
we all chipped in
because the girls uh you know they're
playing in the christmas i don't know
they're doing like a summer tournament
so like the following week they inquired
about going to yankee stadium and the
girls running around the bases it's an
afternoon game it's just something nice
you know but i didn't i do want to go to
yankee stadium i love the yankees i want
to support the mets i definitely want to
go to baltimore so i'm going to call my
man florentine he's a baltimorial fan
and go down there i miss that stadium i
haven't been in that stadium since the
90s when i used to do comedy in
baltimore
and the guy would give me tickets and i
would have five dollars in my pocket and
i would walk around
and smell boo powers ribs or whatever
the [__] he cooks over there and wish i
had a dollar so i could get something to
[__] eat
and you know by the end of the night i
was talking to the ushers
i talked to the old guy he was [__]
phenomenal after talking to him i told
him i needed a retirement job here like
this is great he loved it i i was
looking at him and i'm like how jealous
i'm i am
he was a mailman for whatever and then
he goes i retired after a year my kids
told me i couldn't sit at home no more
and i was looking at him and i'm like
yeah it's memorial day this guy's
working from four to maybe nine
times really too really
yeah
[__] i would love to be one of those old
dudes
that's okay i was standing yesterday
that was great
listen i did a lot better than i
anticipated yesterday i i really did i
was uh
but it's really weird how negativity
works how people try to
talk you into
you know they'll paint the picture that
is so horrible for you that you don't
want to do anything
but i'm happy i went i i really want to
thank the
the people who run that stadium and the
phillies i mean what the guy was like
how dare you come down here unannounced
uh they could have helped you out i
didn't i don't want any help i don't
want
a special booth i don't know i just want
my kid to grow their you know what i'm
saying what good is going to a baseball
game if you're going to [__] be an
elitist
what good is it if i'm sitting there
with my daughter in a box with glass and
she's not sweating you go to a baseball
game to sweat you go to a baseball game
to yell you go to a bait you know and
these uh like i hear the yankee stadium
is a little
they're a little [__] woke you know
for a new york stadium because you get
all those new york people in there
and they're a little woke so you know i
i just
i grew up at shea stadium guys yesterday
i relived [__] memories that uh
i didn't even know i had anymore
how many games i went to shea stadium
with my mother and
she'd drink and smoke pot and i'd be
embarrassed and i'd disappear
and i'd go buy a mets hat and it was uh
it's just a really great experience guys
i don't know what your
financial situation is i'm not here to
you know but if you get a chance
you know
again it doesn't have to be the best
tickets in the world it could be
shitty tickets to your kids
they're gonna [__] love it i i
thought my daughter wouldn't wasn't
gonna love it holy [__] she was serious
about it and they kept it in foul balls
in like 10 rows before us
i got to be honest here she was hot like
dad now come on taking the pictures
would throw the ball in there it was all
10 rows before us in both directions
and she wouldn't have a chance to
[__] put the glove on and stuff
so i guys i was uh
i was just blown the [__] away like i
said
whatever i was feeling from the week
disappeared at a [__] baseball game
it's uh surreal i was going
i took my uncle to see the giants every
year twice a year i took him to dodger
stadium and
we watched all nine innings and uh and
yesterday it went into tentatives
and guys it was like nothing i was
having such a good time
around me that
inside of me i didn't feel the heat it
really didn't matter my balls were
sweaty i came home took a shower and it
was all [__] forgotten
and now
i'm excited as [__] for this weekend
guys i haven't been
i'm excited to see joe i'm excited to
get on stage if i'm on a bomb i'm going
to bomb i don't give a [__] you know i'm
only going to do the best i can
i've written a couple jokes i got a
story or two and that's the best i could
do you know
and then i got two or three weeks to
prepare for birch tour and then uh
we see what's left over in the summer
i'm i'm really fortunate
that i got a chance to
go down and open up for joe you know
they called me from the chappelle camp
really nice guys the the guys from live
nation that i'm friends with
i told
uh my
jimmy's brother danny we went out to
lunch friday and he goes when will you
know about atlantic city i go well it's
one o'clock
dave chappelle goes up at seven and i
haven't heard anything yet
i go if i hear anything it'll be
tomorrow at three o'clock i go that's
how those things usually are
sure enough when do you think my buddy
from
live nation called me 2 51 on saturday
and he goes hey what are you doing i go
nothing
he goes if you like
uh dave would like to have you come down
do the show i go do the show i go i just
wanted to come down and say hello i
don't really
that was last [__] friday saturday
and sunday
so last saturday
like i said they called already my wife
was going to a party uh
an 80s party or something i mean they
already had plans
um
you know mike said if you need a ride i
thought about calling you but i thought
that your wife was working sadly
i'll find somebody to come here so i was
like uh i had like three hours george
was gonna get not get head till five and
with george it could be five thirty
quarter to six
so the show started at seven so i didn't
want to [__] be late so i just passed
on saturday
and my friend danny said that he went by
there and he goes to shonen start till
because he went by like at 7 30. he said
there was so 500 people outside trying
to put their phones and bags and stuff
so they were running late so i kicked
myself in the ass then and then sunday i
had some [__] to do the pool was opening
i had plans joe florentine had a party
which we didn't even make that we ended
up just going to this softball thing and
staying there
and then uh
they hit me up again sunday with a text
and said you're more than welcome to
come tonight but again
i was already buried in my family and
events and what the [__] were we doing
so
we had a pass i heard the shows were
great dave's always a [__] savage
nelly was down there
next door performing so somebody had
sent me an email that nellie said hello
so you know i blew it but i'm really
excited about this weekend it's the mgm
grand
if you haven't got your tickets yet it's
myself
tony hinchcliffe and uncle joe uh
i don't know um it's so one show a night
saturday one show friday eight o'clock
be there be square the tickets are a
little pricey i get it
um
but it'll be a good time it's also the
food and beverage festival
down atlantic city
beer beer beer festival
so that'll be a a nice getaway for you
guys because that's saturday and sunday
so if you come downside if you get a
cheap room we'll be there
uh the new batch of [__] uh rainbow
ruts is out and
i'm giving mike the new batcher a white
truffle is out
white truffle i don't even know what
percentage it is but it's [__] up
there
and uh white truffles up there and i
know for a fact the new rainbow ruts is
like 37
on the new white truffle so you know we
ain't [__] around over at the ice
cream shop
over at ziki with the laughing gas label
everything is beautiful guys
uh happy memorial day weekend i know
some of you is taking the whole week off
because you got it like that suckers
like uh still gotta [__] grind it out
and that's it and that's that i hope you
enjoyed today's podcast we'll get back
to guests next week and what we're gonna
[__] do for the summer and that's it
it's onward and [__] forward [__]
tuckers it's june 1st the rent is due
that's it now for a word for my
[__] sponsors jack have a great
week
all right i want to thank you guys great
podcast today i had a great time telling
your story philadelphia [__] the best
where the brothers aren't held down
either that's another great thing about
that brother's a slinging dick with
three hands in philadelphia and
everybody loves them the joint is
brought to you by
it listen when it comes to your health
we're here for you honored i've been
working with them for close to 11 years
rogan turned me on to them the alpha
brain the shroom tech sport the shroom
tech immune the new mood to relax you
but the only way you'll learn about is
by going to haunted.com reading
about the supplements read about the
mace the kettlebells the club bats on it
can help you in more ways than one but
it starts by you going to
press honor.com
co joey and get 10 off
your first order and the joint is also
brought to you by cbd lion
listen when it comes to cbd nobody is
betting the lion go to cbdline.com
read up on a third-party lab results and
how cbd can help you when you find
something you like
put in code joey joint or church
and receive 10 percent off your first
order i want to thank honett i want to
thank cbd lion
i want to thank uh
what the other company here
i don't even know anymore
blue chew
that's right liquid iv i want to thank
all you guys for having being on the
show this week and for your support and
i want to thank you guys have a great
week
enjoy the weekend and i'll see you
[__]
friday and saturday atlantic city on
monday morning
back here on the joint have a great day
uncle joey loves you
[Music]
you